ALBERT LIN: I'm deep
inside an ancient pyramid
on the trail of a
mysterious Umayyad
dynasty called the Snake Kings.
I'm so far into the heart of the
pyramid, my radio doesn't work.
Within these twisting tunnels,
it's impossible to know
just how deep I am.
But if my team
can skin it, we'll
find out for the first
time, whether it still
holds undiscovered depths
for Sandra and Francisco
to explore.
[coughing]
It's so humid in here and muggy.
I can barely breathe.
Wow.
Eventually, the tunnel ends.
It feels like I'm inside
the center of a mountain.
And yet, here are these crypts.
Somebody's life
was lived, and then
this place was built to honor
their life after they died.
Wow, this wasn't
meant for the living.
This is the chamber
for the dead.
It feels like we
shouldn't be here.
Well, come on, guys, let's
get out of here, get some air.
Hey, you made it.
[sighs] It was just like
nothing I've ever seen before,
you know, like a spiral
staircase descending
all the way to the bottom.
Oh, what an experience.
Inside, my team
are already at work
scanning the tunnel system.
A series of revolving lasers
fire millions of beams of light
every second, reaching every
last square inch of the tunnel.
Later, with the scan complete,
I show Francisco and Sandra
the results.
Are you ready for this?
This is the front.
SANDRA: Mm-hmm.
Ah!
FRANCISCO: Wow, yes!
SANDRA: Oh, yes.
Basically, it's an
X-ray of the whole thing.
Yeah, this is really
exciting for us.
ALBERT LIN: The new scans
reveal a massive surprise.
FRANCISCO: It looks like we're
2 or 3 meters above bedrock.
Typically, the first king
gets buried in the bedrock.
And then whoever comes
after gets buried
in the building above it.
And so if this is
not in bedrock,
it means there is another
building below it.
ALBERT LIN: The new data
that we just collected shows
that Sandra and
Francisco still have
further to go to
investigate the origins
of this mysterious city.